okay
right i believe we're going live now so
i'll start the meeting
good afternoon welcome to our virtual
planning meeting of the
sorry virtual meeting of planning
committee a i should say my name's
councillor kendall i'll be chairing
uh the meeting this evening um before we
get started you can just run through
very quickly a few pieces of information
uh to make you aware
i'm sure you've any speakers have
already received etiquette virtual
meetings in advance but the most
important parts are that you
please ensure the device you're using is
charged or charging at the moment
please ensure that your mutual
microphone when not speaking
um and when you're finished speaking
please turn off your microphone
immediately but don't leave the meeting
because we may have questions for you
afterwards please also ensure that all
devices mobile device which i'm going to
quickly check now are set
silent so they won't interrupt the
meeting either
so i'm done so i'm sorted um
if there are any problems with it during
the course of the meeting they drop
out please make your best endeavors to
rejoin as quickly as poss as possible
should a member of the committee not be
able to rejoin it will be deemed that
they have left the meeting
uh the meeting will continue um as long
as it remains quite
right uh if we can very quickly get make
sure we've got all of our committee
members please so if i go to anne banks
could you do a very quick roll call
for us if you want to start with me
councillor kendall present and i can
hear and see proceedings
thank you chairman councillor adam
uh councillor adam here i can see in
here all the proceedings thanks
okay councillor dickson councillor dixon
here i can see
and hear perfectly fine thank you thank
you councillor eden
councillor ed and i can see and hear
everything thank you
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jennings here i can hear and see your
proceedings
thank you councillor parry uh councillor
parry here i can see
and hear all the proceedings thank you
thank you and councillor richards
councillor richards i can see and hear
all
thank proceedings excellent thank you
anne
um if i can just remind councils if they
wish to speak on a particular item
during the course of the meeting please
indicate in the uh
chat box on the right hand side of your
screen and i'll then bring you in an
appropriate moment
uh now we need to move to the
introduction of the officers uh if i
call out your first
name uh would you introduce yourself and
your role tonight please
and and banks from committee services
thank you uh mesa merchandise from legal
services
thank you alice alex kosnet planning
manager
thank you sarah sarah shawwark planning
officer
allison allison willis senior play
officer
joe joseph planning officer
and victoria victoria chadway senior
planning officer
wonderful thank you to everybody uh just
introduce yourselves
brilliant let's move on uh for members
of the public just make you aware of
course that tonight's meeting is being
broadcast live
um and uh remind public speakers that
you are
participating in the meeting and you're
consenting therefore
to the broadcaster and of course that
your image and sound recordings
may be used for training purposes as
well in the future
um public speakers you'll be given 30
seconds warning uh
coming towards the end of your time
speaking um
and then of course as i mentioned
earlier please do stay in the meeting
should there be any questions for you
from the committee to remind
members of the committee that voting
when it happens you'll be asked to
say your name and then very clearly for
against or abstain that is the
piece of information out of the way for
the virtual meetings so we can now move
to
our first um item on the agenda
which is apologies for absence not
german
wonderful thank you very much uh item
two disclosure of interests
if i kick this one off please i've
received a number of emails for items
three on our agenda tonight which is the
first application has there anybody else
received those
i'll show you for the purpose of the
minutes if we can just show that
most people on the committee will also
receive those as well via email thank
you
are there any other further disclosure
of interests other than those ones
please
no in that case
thank you right it seems we have no
minutes to approve on this occasion
we moved to our first planning
application tonight
which is found on page one of your
agenda
and it's application reference nineteen
slash
zero zero one eight two
is for the erection of 10 dwellings and
associated parking
landscaping public open space and
ancillary
infrastructure our presenting officer on
this application is
allison willis allison over to you
thank you mr chairman can everybody see
the first slide
yes right thank you this is an
application
on a site on the northwestern edge of
southern location
shown by the black dot
this is a full application for the
erection of ten dwellings and associated
parking landscaping
public open space and ancillary
infrastructure
there is a right-of-way running past the
site to the south
that's here
here is an aerial view of the site
showing the application site colored in
red the adjacent roads
solas gardens flint close quarry road
and little terrace avenue have been
fully developed since this photo
the plot is approximately half an acre
sorry half a hectare
excluding the existing attenuation pond
it's made up of open grassland with
existing perimeter hedging to this
to the west and south which is being
retained
the site slopes up from the western
corner rising by approximately
4.5 meters
this is an extract from the core
strategy the site is within
sou2 allocation which was allocated for
approximately
165 homes this is not an absolute number
whilst this proposal increases the
number of dwellings proposed
within the allocation as a whole 175
total versus the allocation for 165
it does not extend the proposals outside
of the allocated area in the plan
the addition of 10 further houses is not
considered to be a significant increase
the applicant has demonstrated a layout
in which
which is in line with current standards
in the spd and the
highway network was designed to
accommodate this slight increase
this the site area with within so2
was previously included as one of three
attenuation drainage basins
this area here as the construction phase
of the larger housing screen
progressed however it became clear that
a third additional drainage basin was no
longer required
so this space was surplus
this slide shows the proposed layout
one five bed three four beds three three
beds
one two bed and two three bed bungalows
the houses are two story in height along
with two bungalows on plots five and six
here all houses are to be offered for
sale in the open market
section 106 has been drafted as an
off-site affordable housing contribution
will be required the additional housing
will utilize the adjacent attenuation
basin
here the proposals include electric
vehicle charging points
visitor parking
the layout has three visit visitor
spaces when the spd requirement would
only be for two
it's got secure cycle storage and
natural play space with native trees and
shrubs
here in this area a landscape buffer
along with southern boundary is enhanced
with
additional trees here
hedging and trees on the western
boundary
along here are to be retained and
maintained still by taylor wimpy as it's
outside the application site
a number of biodiversity enhancements
are proposed by the applicant including
24 native trees 80 square meters of
hazel cops
85 meters of gelder rose hedge
species-rich meadow grass and four
integrated back boxes
and bird boxes on existing trees on the
southern boundary
this slide shows an illustrative photo
montage taken from
the red star by sweeping
south to north from here
up around up to the houses
it's taken in winter when there was
minimum tree cover
it shows the existing hedgerow along the
boundary
along here
this slide um you can see the existing
boundary hedge
that would be retained around here
and the adjacent attenuation basin
which the new housing would utilize
this slide shows the neighboring housing
to the north and east of the site
and then this slide is an illustrative
street scene
the houses are to be constructed from
brick with
a tiled roof
that's the end of the presentation mr
chairman there's one update as shown on
the update sheet
and the recommendation is that the
application be granted
subject to the completion of the section
106 agreement
and the conditions and notes as referred
to in the officer report and update
sheet
the detailed wording and numbering of
which is granted to officers
thank you
thank you allison uh lovely stuff
brilliant
okay um if we go to our first speaker
please
michael boswell a resident who is
objecting please
mr boswell are you there
mr boswell
mr boswell i think you just need to
press
star six to unmute yourself
and i wonder if should we perhaps go to
our next speaker do you think and maybe
see if we can get miss boswell back in
later yeah he's
he's online he's definitely in the
meeting
um i hear a voice great
hello hello mr boswell
uh michael boswell can you hear me yes
we've got you now thank you welcome sir
it's nice to hear you
right okay so mr boswell you have uh
three me
uh three minutes to address the meeting
uh we'll give you a warning at the last
30 seconds if that's okay
and at the end of your time please don't
hang up do stay in the meeting
because it may be that members of the
committee have questions for you
is that okay
i think we met mr boswell have we lost
you again
he's still in the meeting he's there
he's maybe just having difficulty on
muting
star six cent one mute
perhaps if we just give him a few
seconds because he has adopted himself
again
i'm here i'm here are we doing hello
that's fine i can hear you mr boswell so
i think should we proceed if you're
happy to go ahead
it sounds like he may be getting some
interference he might have
um a laptop or something playing in the
background so if you can hear me
mr boswell could you perhaps mute the
device that you are playing the meeting
through
and then just use your telephone
in addition if you can hear me you don't
need to keep on muting yourself
as soon as you are unmuted you can speak
and you'll stay
unmuted
right i think perhaps shall we should we
move to our next speaker maybe
and come back to mr paul's boswell do
you think
do we ha mr boswell if you can hear me
we will come back to you don't worry
just stay in the meeting we'll just
shuffle around the order slightly
uh we'll instead go to the uh the agent
for the applicant uh mr john williams mr
williams are you
in the meeting
mr williams
hello can you hear me
hello hello mr williams
i think there's a considerable delay
i think it's about 10 seconds i think
we're working it out
so mr williams i trust that you're in
the meeting and you can hear us
hello hello
chairman do you want to call one of them
through again they are both there
one is muted and one isn't currently
yeah i think
i think council richards makes a good
suggestion i think
um all speakers need to turn off the
devices that they're watching the
meeting on
or at least mute them and then only use
your phone to speak in the meeting so
that's i think the problem is i still
think there's a 10 second delay
so i'm going to stop speaking for and
then hopefully the moment anybody hears
this they can begin speaking
and we can we can start whoever starts
speaking please start with your name i'm
hoping it's gonna be mr williams
so mr williams you may speak now
we can hear you now mr williams
chairman should we if if you want to go
to the board member perhaps if the ward
member is happy to go ahead and then
we can go offline and we can ring these
two speakers up and just see
what the issues are yes and i think
that's probably a good idea and if you
can or somebody from democratic service
can do that while we move hopefully to
uh
councillor bromwich our ward member uh
councillor bromwich uh you know the
routine you have five minutes
uh over to you sir good evening sorry
about
god says so wish to launch the objection
on the following grounds the first
factor to consider is there is a
five-year land supply
we're already in excess of the stratford
district so it's actually not
much demonstratable need for this
particularly in salvo
i'd like to point out two members of the
committee when the planning officer says
it's a small development of 10 in the
course strategy is adopted
southern was to take 1082
of the housing allocation for the rural
centres
that equates to 29.3 percent
of the royal centre's total homes
also in the core strategy is term it
states quite clearly there should be a
fair and even distribution
across the district these little tackles
which have already happened to sou-3
and there is another one in the pipeline
for sou-1
are starting to have a significant
impact and so whilst 10 doesn't seem
a lot in a small picture in the picture
of the royal center itself it is now
starting to have
impacts by granting this application it
would mean then your
3.8 increase on the total numbers of
salvo
already from the adopted course strategy
part of the reason 165 was originally
agreed to sou2
was following consultation with the town
council at the time of which i was a
member
and then we had to take sou-3 on in
addition
to what was this agreed for so use one
and two
that added over 500 houses which equates
to about a third increase of the housing
stock
because of this there's been significant
impact on the
infrastructure town particularly in the
schools where we have a
vastly over subscribed college we have
an over
subscribed prime with two primary
schools and one which is currently under
subscribed
which happens to be the first one away
from this proposed development
it's also worth pointing out as well as
these grounds within the core strategy
for review for potential refusal and a
five-year land supply as a potential
refusal
the national planning policy framework
does also state that communities
should have an involvement on their
housing allocations
that again is legal grounds for any
refusal
the deficit of housing in southern is in
particular social house not private
housing which there is a huge glut of
on sou3 on my own estate here on
sou-1 plus demanders crop development
where
currently they reserve struggling to
actually sell houses
and i have a big concern that this glut
will lead to lots of new builds which
are not being occupied
because there is no provision in
particular now on this
for any improvement on the deficit of
social housing other than providing some
money
there are issues in sound as well with a
deficit of open
space and it was hoped by the residents
particularly on the
sou2 side that they could actually have
a proper open spacing
which could be developed up and there
have been discussions within the
community
and that is what their preferred option
is again i refer to the national
planning policy framework
which still say a community should have
its input we have been hampered by the
lack of a
proper neighborhood plan and that is
nowhere near near development
although certain stages are also again
stressing they would like open
provisions upon the north of southern
which shows a big deficit
there is also i have a big concern here
about the lack of a biodiversity impact
assessment
although the county council originally
turned around and said they would like
one
and if there wasn't one they said this
application would be deferred or refused
subsequently there was another officer
who came back and said none was
necessary
given that the amount of times the state
has been established now which is three
or four years since construction started
and was completed a couple of years ago
i think that's actually an important
essential in line with our existing
council policies
there has also been issues raised by
existing residents about
drainage water and problems they have
had there
and there's also the issue that whilst
we turn around and
cut the number upon that on the estate
whether that was a wise
move to actually undertake given the
experiences residents are now
raising with myself in particular and
certain officers within the council none
of these have been
addressed yet in summing up i believe
the committee has personally legal
grounds to actually refuse this
application within
national planning policy framework
course strategy and existing council
policies
and we have to bear in mind in mind the
cumulative effect of these
small developments throughout our
communities
thank you very much folks thank you
councillor bromwich thank you very much
um do we have any questions from the
committee please
for the ward member please indicate in
the chat
i've given a few seconds so there are no
questions coming up in the chat
counselor
so thank you very much for your time
this evening thank you very much
thank you right we i'll go just quickly
ask and banks do we have the other
speakers ready now
we do chairman both of them are in the
meeting and
unmuted unmuted excellent well in that
case i suggest we
resume our running order so we'll go to
the objectives first
is mr michael boswell miss boswell
uh you heard preamble earlier i'm sure
there's gonna be another delay on the
line
so i'm just gonna say you have three
minutes please stay in the meeting at
the end
um and we'll give you a warning at 30
seconds over to you sir
could i just check the committee can
hear me yes
okay good evening um southern has seen a
significant number of houses constructed
over the last few years
in excess of the core strategy with the
local infrastructure struggling to keep
up
the leisure centre is overcrowded
college applications increase
increasingly oversubscribed each year
this year 564
to 271 places accepted the three major
developments
still under construction and many
properties still for sale
building more and more homes in southern
will put this put further pressure on
this infrastructure
although it's only an additional small
number of houses will this then set a
precedent
to other developers uh wanting to build
around sell them
using the application as a reference
our main concern with the planning
proposal is health and safety of
existing residents
the amount of construction traffic that
will need to travel through lilly meadow
the proposed site is located at the far
end of the current development
it's accessed by the only through road
through linny meadow with a blind
narrow 90 degree corner to negotiate
there's no provision for construction
traffic to turn around
safely and the children's play park will
be passed by all traffic to site
physically the road is not wide enough
for a lorry and a parked car to park
each other
for health and safety reasons taylor
wimpey would not allow the park to be
used by residents
while construction vehicles were still
on site so how is this application
different
with machinery and delivery six days a
week proposed eight a.m to six pm
would the convenience committee consider
our comments to reduce the proposed
number of houses on the application the
original application by taylor wimpy
underpinning decision item 4 states
only 165 houses were permitted as it was
the maximum
that could be acceptably accommodated
without causing visual harm
and adverse effects on highway safety
local infrastructure
and the environment the committee report
item 10 visual report were concerned the
southwest border would be visible from
the countryside
they considered the long-term vision
impact could be mitigated
with a long-term landscape plan by
planting significant amounts of trees
taylor wimpy have fulfilled this plots
one to four
propose that two stories will clearly be
visible from the countryside
so how does this fit in with the visual
impacts from the original
application surely this condition must
still exist
we are concerned under the current
design visitors would have no choice but
to park causing an obstruction
even though three spaces are proposed
also under the current roadway design a
residence pathway will need to be
completely removed to allow for a new
road to
be created this will leave them no safe
access to their property
if plots one to four were removed the
roadway could then be accommodated at a
different angle
the proposed development would not be
visible from the countryside
it would provide additional open space
lacking inside of them and hopefully
will reduce the
overall level of construction traffic
going through lily meadow
thank you for your time and consider our
comments
thank you very much mr boswell i
appreciate that uh
do you have any questions from the
committee
i'll just ask you a moment in the chat
it doesn't appear to be anything uh mr
boswell thank you very much for your
time tonight and many apologies for the
delays getting you in tonight we do
appreciate your time thank you very much
thank you very much thank you uh we'll
move then to our next speaker
this is uh john williams the agent for
the applicant mr williams
i trust you and you are there this time
and you understand the rules
you will have three minutes uh at the
end of which please stay on the line for
any questions we'll give you a warning
at 30 seconds
thank you good evening chair members my
name is john williams i'm the
applicant's agent
i'm a director of planet planning and
development and a chartered town planner
i would use my minutes to try to
reassure this committee
on concerns which have been raised by
objectives
firstly traffic the impact of an
additional 10 new homes will be very
modest
your highway authority agrees and
considers that the existing state road
will continue to operate adequately
construction traffic will be managed to
minimize disruption to existing
households
a construction management plan will be
agreed with your officers to discharge a
planning condition for
it will include measures such as wheel
washing road sweeping and restrictions
on delivery times of materials
drainage surface water runoff will drain
to the existing balancing pond
which will operate within its design
capacity you will lead local flood
authority raises no objection
on car parking each home will be
allocated parking spaces which complies
with your spd
and will have access to electric vehicle
charging points
loss of open space members this parcel
of land was never intended to be used
for open space
your officers have confirmed that the
lily meadows estate has adequate public
space
this pass of land was proposed for
balancing pond which is no longer
required
but rather than losing public space this
development will create new place space
designed for younger children which will
be accessible to existing and new
residents
in fact the amount of new open space
exceeds your
policy requirements it will be
positioned in the northeastern corner of
the development
which will increase the separation
distance between the new homes and the
existing
on boundary treatment the development is
pulled back some six meters from the
side southern boundary
the existing trees on the southern
boundary will be retained
and my final point relates to the
housing mix the town council
asked us to provide some bungalows we
have done that
the proposals have been criticized for
not including affordable homes
but your policy cs18 does not expect
schemes of ten houses to include
affordable housing
instead the policy asks for a commuted
payment this has been agreed
a section 106 agreement has been
prepared and is ready for signature
it will commit a payment of just under
275
000 pounds specifically for the delivery
of affordable housing
elsewhere across the district the
development will also
pay a sill payment of just under 94
000 pounds chair this is a good proposal
it complies with your planning policies
and it should be supported
we hope that this committee will make
the right decision and approve planning
permission
as recommended by your officers thank
you
thank you very much mr williams any
questions then from the committee
for the agents for the applicant's agent
pleasure to say
just make a wait a moment for anything
i'm saying shaking heads
in that case mr williams thank you very
much for your time this evening again
apologies for the slight technical
issues we experienced earlier on the
meeting
thank you very much for your time thank
you thank you
okay we've had the ward member as well
so in which case we should now move to
any points of clarification
from the committee if you'd like to
indicate please any points of
clarification
well i'll read that as none in which
case we move to the debate
who would like to start suffering the
debate for this application
councillor parry good evening chairman
thank you very much
um it was interesting to note um
very thorough report if i may say there
is no representation from southern town
council
obviously if there were concerns about
objection
uh regarding this application i think
southern town council would have made
some comments from my perspective um the
application
is in line with cs15 of the course
strategy
as the site is is within the southern ii
allocation um and i'd like to go forward
straight
to a proposal to grant uh permission for
this particular
application thank you very much
councillor uh parry uh i'll run down the
speakers uh councillor richards
uh you'd like to speak in your speaking
to second do you want to add anything to
that
thanks sharon council richard's here um
i don't think there's any me to
say anything further i think councillor
parry has wrapped it up quite nicely i'm
happy the second
thank you councillor richards i i do
agree with you uh councillor adam
uh would you like to speak on this
thank you very much um it was just a
matter of principle around
around it really i think generally
speaking there isn't
um anything in terms of planning reasons
set out in the
set out in the officers report um but i
think that the concerns raised by the
ward member
uh do represent um similar concerns of
the community and and
of of saudi in general um in that there
we are at risk of of losing the
potential for
uh five-year rolling how housing supply
into the into the next core strategy
i think this should be considered to
have more weight
than than historically we've been giving
it um
and i think given that there are um
[Music]
around uh three percent over already in
southam of the development and 13
over across the district in terms of
housing in
main rural centers i don't think i can
support this on that principle
um but i can't see any planning reasons
to to lodge a formal
um objection so i shall be
abstaining thank you very much cancer
adam um if there's no one else wishing
to speak
i'll give it a second
right in that case um i think we need to
move to
a roll call vote the app the um
it has been proposed and it's been
seconded i'm just checking my update
sheet to make sure there's nothing else
we need to mention here
uh that's preferred uh delivery open
space
that's fine everything controlled by
obligations right
so uh the application has been proposed
it's been seconded
uh and banks can we go free to you for a
roll call please
yes chairman we'll start with yourself
councillor kendall
four thank you councillor adam
councillor adam obstain
thank you councillor dixon councillor
dixon
for thank you councillor eden
councillor eden for
councillor jennings
councillor jennings ball
councillor parry councillor parry four
and councillor richards councillor
richards four
that's six four with one abstention
chairman
thank you very much adam in that case
the committee resolves to grant
application reference nineteen slash
zero zero one
uh eight two slash ful and we'll pause
to take a five minute uh adjournment so
we can get the next
application up so five minutes only
please everybody thank you
and we have to call us in
yes we have done here chairman oh thank
you okay
um right let's uh continue the meeting
then so
without further ado we go to our next uh
application tonight which is item four
and found on page 13 of your agenda this
is application reference
uh 1903415
ful and it's for the land adjacent to
bridgetown house british towns trafford
haven
uh this for the erection of six dwelling
houses together with access drive sewers
and associated external
works uh presenting officer for this is
sarah chadwick sarah
over to you the presentation is visible
on the screen
perfect thank you thank you chairman
thank you the application site is within
the built-up area boundary of
stratford-upon-avon indicated by the
black dot on this plan
here we see a plan of the application
site the application site is within the
trinity media state
and is currently garden land associated
with bridgetown house which can be seen
here
the site is 0.18 hectares an area and
shares an access of dickens close
which can be seen here the site is level
and is bounded on three sides by
residential development with a play area
like located adjacent to the southwest
boundary
seen here
this is a full planning application for
the erection of six dwellings with
associated secure cycle storage bin
straws
hard surfacing and landscaping
off-street parking is provided adjacent
to each of the proposed dwellings with
two visitor spaces located here
and here
an elevation of plot 2 can be seen on
this slide with some floor plans
the dwellings of the plots one two and
six would be three bed with plots three
four and five being two bed
they would all feature porches and
chimneys
the dwellings would extend to a height
of eight point one meters the elevations
of plots three four and five can be seen
on this slide again with the floor plans
below
here this photo was taken stood to the
south east of bridgen house looking in
an easterly direction towards dickens
close
seen here on the left and kingsley
closed seen here on the right
this photograph is taken looking in a
north easterly direction
over the existing boundary wall down
dickens close where the access will be
located
this photograph is taken looking in a
northwest westerly direction back to
woodsbridge townhouse
um with number three dickens clothes
shown on the right here
this final image is taken looking down
dickens clothes towards where the site
access would be
uh chairman there are three updates as
referred to in the update sheet the
principle of development is acceptable
as is the design impact on neighboring
immunity and highway safety
the recommendation is therefore to
approve the application subject to the
conditions as detailed in the agenda
thank you
thank you very much sarah thank you for
the presentation uh
okay let's crack on with our first
speaker uh hopefully they're on the line
already
mr carlo tarelli please are you there
hello good evening can you hear me
perfect absolutely
we're very relieved it's working much
better lovely so
um you have uh three minutes you can
stay on the line at the end
of your uh speech for any questions and
we'll give you a warning at 30 seconds
if that's okay
yeah that's great thank you over to you
then thank you very much
thank you our main issues are parking
and access new pedestrian access
construction vehicles
and lack of plans details please refer
to the four parking slides highlighting
these daily parking issues
we are at parking capacity due to the
vehicles from the 10 flats their
visitors and residents of other streets
leaving vehicles struggling to enter
often having to exit on the wrong side
of the road the parking in the middle of
the road is a bottleneck that will be
worsened by the increase in traffic
and parking from the new homes that will
struggle past our driveway
as it was not designed for through
traffic and is impossible now for waste
disposal
or emergency vehicles wcc highways
objected to the previous plans and
stated the new plan should demonstrate
the largest vehicle
can pass a parked vehicle to enter the
site but the new swept path document
does not show this test
please refer to the previous tracking
plan slide bottom image
we feel the better alternatives to make
this access instead from benjamin road
as a more established through road with
less parking issues and has space front
access road
the new pedestrian access from benjamin
road is unacceptable
because it would change forever the
character of the close as a closed road
and will be used by the residents of the
surrounding roads the developer assured
me
that this was not in his original plans
and it was only submitted to appease the
suggestion by the planning officer
but we do not need nor want to be a
cutthroat benjamin road already enters
wordsworth avenue in two places
there is no need for another access
additionally the planned fencing
bordering betjamin road
is also far too low to stop people
stepping over it even without this
access
the plans show no con consideration for
the access of the large construction
vehicles using dickens clothes
would have a huge impact on residents
and would make access and parking
impossible at times
residents from other streets have also
objected on this basis
the developer verbally advised me he
wants to access this
from betcham and road we cannot
overemphasize how necessary this is
and it would be unreasonable to make us
suffer otherwise
other points plot one there is no detail
to show what the boundary between its
driveway and my driveway would be and
there is no room to accommodate the drop
curve needed for the side of my driveway
and there are no pavements in the new
road so
how would this work practically and for
pedestrian safety
no street lighting is planned and we
will lose the only street light at the
end of our road leaving us
unsafe moving it will reduce parking
options on the pavements also
we object to the demolition of the
existing six-foot high
character wall and fencing bounding
dickens close
and there is no detail of what boundary
material will replace it
the water seconds and may have
architectural merit the ecological
survey was not conducted at a time of
year when the bats
are present another should be scheduled
for the summer and there was no impact
assessed for the large hedgehog presence
in the close
the removal of healthy mature trees in
the coast was not considered
the loss of biodiversity and protective
species will not be compensated in the
close
there are two uh many unanswered
questions through lack of plan details
and to approve these plans would be to
ignore the pragmatic approach
all residents have expressed again our
main issues are parking and access
protecting access construction vehicles
and lack of plan detail thank you
thank you very much uh for that um do we
have any questions uh
for the resident please if you can just
indicate in the chat
anybody
okay thank you councillor dixon
thank you chairman we saw the
photographs there of the cast parts
in uh the access or proposed access road
uh our papers indicate that the highway
has been widened to a width of five
meters
can you tell me if those photographs
were taken after the highway was widened
or
prior to it please
are you sorry are you addressing me yes
mr totoro the questions for you
i'm not aware of any widening of the
road i've lived here for
uh 13 years it's never changed size
okay uh council dixon perhaps question
for points of clarification later on if
that's okay
yeah if there are no other questions uh
i don't think they are mr chartres thank
you very much for your time this evening
much appreciated thank you thank you
thanks
uh we'll move then to our next speaker
uh the
applicant's agent mr jonathan thompson
mr thompson are you there
yes can you hear me chairman can hear
you perfectly um
i trust you've heard the previous
statements so
you have three minutes if you stay on
the line at the end of your three
minutes
for any questions and we'll give you a
warning at 30 seconds
over to you good evening members the
application before you this evening is
for six dwellings comprising two and
three bed houses
and is located within the built-up area
boundary obstructed upon avon
the site is located within a sustainable
location with existing residential
development surrounding the site on
three sides
there is also an existing convenience
store within a five-minute walk of the
site
nearby bus stops provide transport links
to the centre of stratford and beyond
a footpath has been provided for within
the site to ensure connectivity and
permeability of this site
into the wider residential environment
the proposed site will be accessed via
an existing road which
is known as dickens close which i
understand has been built to adoptable
standards
concerns have been raised on this
application regarding access into the
site by the county and ward member
in addition to local residents on
dickens close
in order to understand these concerns in
greater detail i arranged a meeting with
the county and ward member in february
together with the applicant
following that meeting the applicant met
with local residents on dickens clothes
to consult them further
i understand that the highway officer
had already undertaken a site visit with
the ward member to see
the proposed site access for himself
county highways issued a consultation
response on the 13th of january
of no objection county highways reviewed
the scheme again in early march and
maintain their position of no objection
and this was confirmed again in writing
on the 25th of march
this application is therefore in
accordance with sdc's policy cs26
and part o of the development
requirements sbd
the scheme before you this evening is of
high quality and well designed
and utilizes good quality materials it
adopts a traditional approach to
development with the introduction of
chimneys as well as brick arches
the applicants focus upon high quality
design has been acknowledged in the
committee report
in response to the declaration of a
climate change emergency
six electrical vehicle charging points
have been designed into the scheme and
water books will be provided within each
property
sustainable construction will be ensured
as the site will be built to the latest
building regulations
a detailed ecological appraisal was
submitted as part of the application and
it has informed the layout of the scheme
the application seeks to retain as much
boundary vegetation as possible
and this will be supplemented with new
native species
the applicant agrees with the county's
view that a biodiversity offset of 0.28
credits is required
and we agree with some in the report a
discussion has in fact been held between
the applicants and the old
with a view to providing the 0.28 credit
offset at the biodiversity project at
old school estates which is just outside
stratford
30 seconds we therefore request the
flexibility in the section 106 agreement
to either pay the sum set out to the
county or
provide our own offset project at the
old school states
policy cs1 says the council will take a
positive approach to applications that
reflect presumption in favor of
sustainable development
therefore i respectfully request that
members endorse your planning officer's
positive recommendation
and grant planning commission thank you
perfect timing thank you very much mr
thompson uh do you have any questions
from the committee
i'll just notify you away from the
chat if there are any
okay the chat is silent in that case mr
thompson thank you very much for your
time tonight is well much appreciated
thank you thank you um okay we go to our
ward member councillor ian fragin please
oh no we don't do it apologies that's
forgotten
councillor francis is unable to join us
tonight but he has sent us the
representation
um that he that uh our banks will now
read out for us please
um yes thank you chairman
um i apologize for not attending the
meeting this evening but i have to be in
london
on the 22nd of july for an important
family engagement which was arranged
long before this date was set to heal
this application
you will note from the committee papers
the reasons for my objection
is more to do with the proposed access
and egress
via dickens clause and that remains to
still be the case particularly during
the construction stage
as far as i can see the committee report
does not contain the final response from
the town council
dated the 14th of april 2020
that they will withdraw their holding
objection on the proviso that a
construction
and environmental plan condition is
imposed
which includes a requirement for a
construction
traffic to use an access point other
than via
dickens claws this decision followed on
for a meeting with the developers who
agreed that they would seek to use
an access point on bitumen road
as district or cancer my objection
remains
until there is documented evidence that
this is the intent
and so i ask that this application be
refused until such time
as that is established
thank you very much and much appreciated
obviously there can be no questions
for the ward member on that one so uh
committee
um points of clarification please
somebody have any questions for the
opposite on this one
any councillor questions of course you
raised
a point earlier would you like to
address that now
thank you chairman yes essentially
obviously we had a situation whereby
the whole emphasis of this application
or the objections of this application is
all about the access
we have a report which indicates i think
that
when the officers were there there was a
problem with vehicles
maneuvering within there and the
problems were highlighted in their
presence
and we see in the report that the
highway has been widened to a width of
five meters
we hear from the objectors who's lived
there for some time that he has no
recollection of this
so can we have a clarification please
yes councillor dixon um mr tartaretti
was referring to a withdrawn application
the tracking plan shown on his slides
was related to that withdrawal
application
i do have the um updated ones for this
live application on a slide if you wish
to see them
um so in the withdrawal application the
highway was 4.5 meters in width
and it's now 5 meters i believe that's
what he was referring to
so if i can come back on that uh is that
it's okay
it's i'm just trying to work out then so
has there been any physical work done to
the highway to extend it or is this
basically a change in the paperwork was
it not measured correctly in the first
place
so dickens closed no changes have been
made
the proposed development the plans
submitted on the withdrawn application
the highway was shown to narrow as it
entered the site
however on this resubmission it's shown
to continue at five meters
in width i think i completely understand
so yes that's fantastic thank you sarah
um uh right do we have any other
questions we can move to uh council adam
thank you um it was hopefully a quick
one
um part of um
council of frankly's comments uh
suggests a contradiction
uh within the the county council's um
consultation saying that he had a verbal
um note from a county council officer
that they didn't take into
account some of the situations which may
arise um which which contradicts the the
statement that's on on the planning
portal
um was this considered as part of the
the assessment
um in terms of their statutory
consultation
um like did you do well we were required
to go back to them essentially on that
um amended plans were submitted
throughout the course of the application
and the highway authority were
reconsulted with their final response
being on the 21st
picture sorry 25th of march um i've been
aware of no other
um correspondence on this i don't know
if alice has anything to add on that
uh thank you sarah no i think just to
reiterate what sarah said obviously we
can only take into account
consultation responses which are
formally submitted to us by county
highways so
i think although that conversation you
know i can't
uh stipulate as to whether it did or
didn't happen on site uh we can only
base the decision on on what's been
formally submitted in a consultation
response
of course yeah that's right um i just
had one other aspect i was going to ask
about
in terms of the consultation um
obviously the
the tracking um diagram that was shown
um on which is on the record and i think
you showed on on the
um your report as well um showed
the the site uh being considered by that
but it didn't show
uh dickens close as part of that as far
as i could tell is that a requirement
for the consul
t to to demonstrate as well
um i can just get up the correct
tracking plan if that will be
very helpful useful thank you yeah two
seconds
so there we have the oh whoops
that's the fire vehicle one so it
you can see there that there's the
continuation of dickens clothes
at the top right um
again alice may wish to weigh in here
but this is all that's been shown on
submitted plans
so and here is the refuse vehicle
yeah so again i i would just reiterate i
mean we've only obviously got the
tracking plans for the proposed
development because that's the only
thing we're assessing here
um there's no changes proposed to
dickens close so any existing
arrangement can essentially continue
and obviously in this case because we
are just extending the road down
um and we know that the road is staying
at the same width
this just demonstrates that going that
extra distance they can still access
turn and come back out and afford gear
okay thanks very much
thank you okay uh we one more question
from uh councillor dixon
thank you chairman um amongst the
recommendations uh
item five construction management plan
um what sort of control do we have over
that and
regarding the county and the access
because it seems as though there were
some discussions that
people would like to have access from
benjamin road is that something that we
can introduce at that stage and include
or is that already not an option at all
this is something that has not been
discussed with me it appears there were
discussions between
the objectives and the agent about this
um
there is a pedestrian access onto
betcham road but there will be no
vehicular access
um there i i do know that the town
council have raised this as an issue but
it's
not something that we considered
feasible um
again alice i'm not sure if you wish up
way in here yeah yes please i've just
mentioned in the chat if i could if i
could uh come in
and just to clarify like sarah said
obviously some discussions have taken
place about possible construction access
by benjamin road
that may well be a possibility but at
this point in time we can't confirm
what may be acceptable when that
condition comes in to be discharged so
the condition wording would be pretty
general in as much as it would
require construction access to be
detailed as well as other factors such
as times for deliveries
um mud mud cleaning on the road etcetera
um but i don't think we would be
sensible to apply
any sort of requirement within that
condition that access does come from
better monroe because we can't guarantee
at this stage that the highway authority
will agree to that
when a construction management plan
comes in with whatever construction
access is proposed
the highway authority would be consulted
to make sure they're satisfied that the
impact would be acceptable
wonderful thank you okay if there are no
further points of clarification i don't
think there is
uh should we go to the debate who would
like to start
councillor jennings
thank you chairman i as far as i can see
most of these objections seem to be
based on highway issues
but highways have not lodged an
objection
so i can't see any valid planning
reasons to go against the officers
recommendations
to grant it thank you council jennings
um taking your proposal under advisement
so we move to our next speaker
councillor parry please
thank you chairman um i'm in agreement
with councillor jennings
um and i think the important thing to
remember here is the
adverse effect on the immunity of
residents does not
include the execution of the
construction
of a development um whilst it's always
very
inconvenient for nearby residents to
have
development on their doorstep it is not
a planning reason to object
because of the execution of construction
traffic and the other part is
that from a design perspective the ward
member certainly isn't against the
design
we have no objection from warwickshire
county council
and we also have the application
affording to d cs 26
and part o of parking so um
i would be very happy to second um the
proposal from councillor jennings
thank you chair thank you for that
councillor perry yeah we'll look
down as you seconding i i agree again
with what you've said there
uh we'll move to council dixon
thank you chairman i uh i wouldn't
concur with my colleagues
um essentially i think this is an
application which i think has come to us
too soon
uh before it's been sufficiently
investigated
um because the highways haven't objected
does not mean that we cannot be of a
second opinion
or a different opinion and from that
point of view i think those issues
do matter and i will not be supporting
the recommendation
thank you council dixon uh we moved
councillor richards please
thank you chairman uh councillor richard
speaking um i
whilst i agree with uh what council
dixon has just said and that um highways
don't always get it right
we can have an opposing view in this
instance i think they have got it right
our officers have
gone through in uh quite good detail the
uh the layouts and the issues that have
been uh raised over
uh transport and traffic issues um
so i'm entirely happy that we go ahead
uh with a vote and we'll second the
proposal made by councillor jennings
thank you councillor sure i think you
missed the second thing but we've got
the point of what you were saying but
thank you very much
um we now go to council adam please
thank you chairman um my my thoughts are
very similar to councillor dixon's
um i i think the generally speaking the
development looks
uh suitable the parking issues on the
site have been
addressed fairly well but i do have
concerns about the access
um via dickens close um
and um i think there's based on the the
objections
from from residents there is
understandably reasonable doubt as to
the assessment they made by highways so
i
can't um can't support it but similarly
i can't
find a material planning reason
to to submit another proposal
thank you council adam um if there's
nobody else wishing to speak
uh i'll just give it a second i'll add
my thoughts uh
i completely agree with uh with the
proposal here really that
i can't find any solid planning grounds
not to um not to grant this application
uh yes i
fully agree that we can sometimes
disagree with the county council
but on this one i think they've done
their their homework and i think i
i support what they've said so nobody
else wishes to speak on this
i i think we should go then uh anne
banks to the
roll call for the vote uh i'll begin
councillor kendall
four thank you chairman
councillor adam
adam against thank you councillor dixon
councillor dixon against
councillor eden
thank you councillor jennings
councillor jennings for councillor parry
councillor parry for and councillor
richards
councillor richards iv that's five
four and two against chairman
thank you very much for that so the
committee therefore results to
grant application reference nineteen
slash
zero three four one five slash slash ful
um we can move to our next application
we'll take a short
five minute german and then we'll
reconvene thank you
okay
right i think we're ready to resume so
if i could ask everybody to um
rejoin the meeting so they're all ready
to go
okay i think the meeting is now get uh
live again
so we can proceed when i shuffle my
papers for a second
on to item five which is found on page
23 of your agendas
this is application reference nineteen
slash
zero zero six one three slash
r e m and this is for the land of
bamboo road ettington uh it's quite a
long description so i'll summarize uh
submission of a reserve matters
application for matters of appearance
landscaping
layout and scale in connection with the
previously approved application
of fifteen slash zero one zero three
five slash
out um presenting officer is
alison willis before we go to that can i
just confirm
uh with alice given this is a reserve
matters
i just want to make sure i'm correct in
understanding this means that the
principle of the development and the
access has already been agreed and
is is finalized this is this application
is purely
for the uh landscaping appearances and
etc can you confirm that for me please
alice
yes actually i can confirm that the
outline related to the principle and
access so it fully considered those and
accepted those
this application before members this
evening is just for matters relating to
appearance
landscaping layout and scale
perfect thank you very much alice
allison willis apologies for cutting in
there uh
presentation over to you then please
thank you
alison are you i think you're a mute at
the moment
apologies uh can everybody see my screen
open i can see it and i can see the
pointer moving perfectly
over to you guys thank you and as
alice has just confirmed this is a
reserved matters application on a site
on the northeastern edge of edmonton
location as shown on the black dot
[Music]
the site has outline planning permission
for up to 14 dwellings
involving the demolition of number 81
banbury road to create the access to the
site
just here access was approved at outline
stage and this reserve matters
application is to determine
layout appearance landscaping and scale
there's a right-of-way running past the
site to the north
here
[Music]
here is a recent aerial view of the site
showing the application site outlined in
red
the plot is approximately 0.9 hectares
made up of open grassland with existing
perimeter hedging into the southwest and
southeast
along this boundary and this boundary
the site slopes diagonally from
northeast to west rising by
approximately five meters from
corner to corner
the site lies within the built-up area
boundary of eddington and is shown as a
housing commitment
here the ndp was approved after the
approval of the outline application
this slide shows the proposed layout
14 dwellings in all seven two bed and
seven three bed two bungalows on plots
four and ten
shown by the with blue roofs here and
here
it's to be constructed from brick with
tiled roofs
and the proposals include electric
vehicle charging points
a permanently wet attenuation basin
a footpath link through the open space
here joining up with the right of way to
the north
additional native tree and shop planting
around the site
and the an easement along the eastern
boundary
here gives you an opportunity for
additional landscaping
the separation distances between the new
houses
and the houses on bamboo road are
in excess of 25 meters here and here
additionally the house on plot 4 is a
bungalow
and the house on plot one has no side
facing windows
[Music]
five of the houses are affordable four
social rent and one shared ownership in
line with the section 106
um an rsl a social landlord has been
identified at this point
this slide shows the photo montage of
the site taken from the north of the
site looking towards the back of the
existing houses on banbury road
the middle of the slide shows the
location of the house that would be
demolished
that one the middle
and you can also see where the existing
right-of-way comes into the site
you can see the boundary hedging here
that will be
retained
the two photos to the left of the
slide um show the front and rear of the
house that will be demolished to create
the new access
and the photo on the top right shows
um a view along bamboo road
and the application site is behind these
buildings
the photo on the bottom right this photo
shows a wider view of this at the
southwestern boundary with hedgerows
to the right of the picture being left
to grow taller
affording more privacy so here
so mr chairman um
there is one update as per the update
sheet
and the recommendation is that the
reserve matters be approved subject to
conditions and notes outlined in the
report
and on the update sheet for the reasons
detailed in the report
the wording and numbering left to
officers
thanks very much
[Music]
thank you allison that's wonderful
excellent stuff right
we go to our first speaker then this is
councillor ruth
hawksworth from eddington parish council
uh councillor hawksworth are you
are you there
remembering it's star six to unmute
hello sorry you say i'm
here i was just trying to just trying to
mute
my um speaker then
okay no it's okay it's
surreal hearing my own voice back that's
okay no
in that case you have three minutes uh
if you remain on the line at the end of
those three minutes for any questions
from the committee
and we'll give you a warning in 30
seconds if that's okay
thank you over to you
good evening an opportunity was recently
created by building repairs on the
opposite side of banbury road
to photograph the proposed development
site at roof level
please view the picture submitted it is
clear the site will impose itself on the
existing properties
plots will have visual intrusion into
upper levels of existing properties
from local knowledge 81 bambi road has
been sold
and no approach has been made by the
developer to the new owners
the parish council asks why this has
been allowed to continue for over a year
when there has been no actual
confirmation that 81 would be available
for demolition
we replied to the planning office
office's delegated report on the 22nd of
may
and presume this has been read surface
water
suds policy indicates the development
should not deliver more water
to an adjacent highway than its
greenfield equivalent
how will this be achieved the proposed
road will be higher than banbury road
and in parts lower than the attenuation
basins
the the provision of attenuation
indicates
inadequate means of discharging water if
it is permanently wet
how will it store excess water
eddington pc created a general policy of
not installing more street lights
and with advice from highways removed
rather than replaced
unsound columns and lanterns outdated
sodium and mercury luminaires on
remaining
columns were replaced with led fittings
adding midnight sensing photocells in
line with highways policy
the planning officer uses imprecise
language not stating no street lights
we would request stratfor district
council respect this policy
and not allow it to be ignored as
occurred with the spitfire development
contaminated land the site had a
previous use as an early petrol filling
station
to approve this application without
discharging this issue is worrying
a large buffer zone has been created on
the southeast boundary protecting a
property
but the design has failed to afford a
similar buffer for properties on the
north west boundary
thus plots one to four have zero
separation with existing properties
highways the delegated report states
highways have raised no objection
in fact highways have previously raised
several objections
we feel that they have been argufied
into submission
piper homes have been allowed to make 56
revisions to this application for
reserved matters
making it almost impossible for a lay
person to understand
changes and respond
since the application of further 36
houses have been built within the
village
there has been a massive year-on-year
increase in traffic volume
particularly hgv ettington speedwatch
volunteers regularly record speeds in
excess of 45 miles an hour
within the village we do not feel the
increase in traffic volume has been
adequately taken into consideration
thank you for your time
thank you very much for that much
appreciated uh do we have any questions
please from the committee for the parish
council
just wait for anything to pop up
okay the chat is silent uh in that case
council hawks thank you very much for
your time tonight it's much appreciated
very helpful thank you
thank you thank you
okay we can go now to our ward member
councillor o'donnell
i believe you're there good evening
hello councilor o'donnell
uh well you know the routine you've got
five minutes
and we may have some questions over to
you
thank you um so committee as you've
heard azerbaijan has had its fair share
of new developments with as council
hawks would mention 36
new homes having been completed since
this application was granted
there is an understandable level of
concern around new development within
the village given the difficult
relationship regarding
the spitfire development a little
further up the road that was a
consistent
item raised at every single one of my
parish council meetings during my first
year as ward member
i'm sure you'll appreciate that as a
result the resident's awareness of
potential issues regards to another
development and developer is heightened
whilst they are not arguing over the
principle for development they are
as a village looking for reassurance and
solutions around concerns they have
raised
hence my reason for bringing this to
committee to ask your considered wisdom
and solution finding skills to address
this
my primary concern is the road safety
aspect of the a422
for that reason if due to covid you've
not been able to drive past the site
i would urge that you visit rather than
google earth it i understand that
highways are now happy but i'm not clear
how having previously been concerned
they now have no issues
regarding access to a road where the
volume and speed in traffic has most
definitely increased above average rate
over the past few years
this could be due to the addition of new
homes in the area and the very popular
caffeine in the machine
the regular speed watch as you've heard
record speeds of 45 miles plus
in a 30 mile zone even though there is
traffic calming at one end of the
village
this is obviously very concerning the
residents are unclear regarding the
actual updates around the plan
56 in total and sadly there's been no
close consultation between the developer
and the parish council or indeed the
ward member
so whilst the developer has adhered to
concerns raised to the planning portal
request by stratfor district planning
department
there's not been any face-to-face
consultation in the latter stages with
the parish council and concerned
residents
which is an unfortunate oversight as
lack of consultation causes unnecessary
concern for our residents
in their ndp eddington state that
etiquette aspires to thrive as a vibrant
distinctive
neighborhood to continue to respect and
reflect the views of its community
to evolve and expand whilst retaining
its unique and distinctive character and
to provide outstanding quality of life
for current and future generations of
residents
there are questions locally regarding
who owns number 81 which is integral to
the planned road entrance and therefore
if it will actually be demolished
now whilst we understand this is not a
planning matter again it adds to the
residents concerns
eddington strictly adheres to no more or
additional street lights as you've heard
and there are concerns over the wording
regarding planned illumination
to refer to the ndp to ask that
proposals have regarded the impact on
tranquility including dark skies
please can we look for clarity and
assurance around this and whilst flood
flood risk management have not raised
concern as long as condition seven is
completed
the local knowledge indicates that
potentially there is a risk of flooding
as many of the gardens along that road
have wells and usually flood all have
surface water during heavy rainfall
therefore does its application adhere to
cs4
there is concern about privacy and
overlooking as you've heard on a couple
of plots and whilst one of them is a
bungalow
it is on the high point in the layout
and the other plot with no side facing
windows felt to be too close
and the lack of buffer on the northwest
boundary lead to very little separation
between existing properties
in plots one to four therefore we
question whether this adheres to cs5
cs9 and cs15 with regard to respecting
the sensitivity to the setting and
existing built form so unusually the
purpose of referring this to committee
is the request for strict and clear
conditions in the construction
management plan
around issues raised tonight along with
the request for regular liaison and
updates between the developer
and parish council and residents during
construction
thank you for your time
thank you very much council o'donnell um
we do have a question already
uh so councillor dixon you have a
question for the ward
uh thank you chairman um both the pirate
the parish council and yourself have
referred to the
increasing traffic along that uh road i
just wondered if you had any data any
actual figures and numbers to support
that
uh contention thank you
i don't personally i'm unsure as to
whether the parish council do
um mine's just from personal experience
of actually being in eddington
a number of times and this is definitely
getting far busier and door-to-door when
we're campaigning it's brought up
regularly about the increase in traffic
thank you thank you thank you so
do we have any other questions from the
committee
if not and thank you very much council
o'donnell
much appreciated your time thank you
thank you
so um with our speakers finished we go
to the points of clarification does
anybody have any questions i'd like to
ask the officers
councillor perry
thank you chairman i just wonder whether
the officers can give greater clarity
on the lighting plan uh for the
development
um particularly that fits in with
the eddington neighborhood development
plan thank you
um thank you councillor harry i would
uh i suppose i assessed
the the need for lighting and i looked
at the
policies in the neighborhood
neighborhood development plan which i've
put on screen i don't know if you can
see that they're not on screen
but yeah so
they aren't there thank you good um
my reading of the policy when i was
assessing the application
was that um new development must have
regard to the value
valued landscape characters skylines and
views etc
and i completely understand um the
issues that the parish council
and the local residents are expressing
and i
i suppose i my appreciation was that
with
appropriate appropriately designed
lighting with
um cows and
low level of lighting and minimal amount
of lighting
um that it may be possible to design
something that satisfy the
safety and immunity needs of new
residents but also
minimize the impact locally um when i
i've discussed it subsequently with the
agent
um and they're
they're quite happy to um accept
conditions or she also
mentioned that she would be quite happy
to remove the street lighting from the
application as well
so that just confirmed that there you're
referring to uh
condition uh number five and
note number three am i correct yeah
thank you thank you very much for that i
think that's that's sorted out alice did
you want to come in
yeah if i could just clarify something
and ali please jump in jump in if you
disagree
um absolutely ali's had those
conversations and the applicants
confirmed
that they would be content with a
condition requiring no street lighting
i think the only thing i would just like
to caveat if the road is being offered
for adoption
to county highways they may not accept
no lighting which i don't think is a
deal breaker because again ali has
checked with the agent who's confirmed
that
they are happy for it not to be offered
for adoption
but if that's so i just thought it would
be worth members being aware of that as
a
as a as a consideration
that's a fair point thank you alice
appreciate that um any other
any other points clarification
from the committee uh nothing's coming
up in the chat
uh ali if you if you want to take that
off the screen now that'll be
fine i think thank you very much and
if if nobody else has any points of
clarification should we go to the um
debate who would like to start us on
[Music]
that
well chairman i was waiting for somebody
else to come in i've been holding back
because i'm always sort of
in there first but someone's got to
start
first of all actually i was really
impressed by it this is a very spacious
layout
i felt um also pleased to see
the number of affordable homes which i'm
sure
um are much needed in ettington and the
surrounding area because ethington's got
a very good village shop
and a very good primary school
obviously we we don't have any
objections
from highways i feel comfortable about
the street lights
having said that it's ex you know i have
a number of my residents where there
aren't street lights and they're calling
for street lights
from a security and safety perspective
so
you can't really win whatever um you put
forward on a planning application
so i'm i'm very comfortable about this
this is reserve matters and i think we
should go straight to approval
and i therefore propose approval thank
you chairman
wonderful thank you councillor perry
don't apologize it's always nice to hear
from you thank you for that
uh we'll note your proposal there uh
does anybody
counselor richards uh jumping into
second councillor
do you want to um speak on the matter as
well
thank you chair uh cancer riches i don't
think i need to say anything more than
cancer perry already has
newt thank you very much councillor uh
council jennings i noticed you're
trying to second although you're a
second too late um
do you wish to speak on mata no i don't
think i need to uh peter richards is up
castle richards has got faster fingers
than me so
well that's okay well all i can do is
agree with
uh councillor parry council jennings
council richards
um yes um
alice is mentioning here with whether
we're happy with the streetlight
condition as recommended
i i gather from your thoughts from what
everyone's saying you
are otherwise i think you'd have said
something otherwise i'm happy with it
and i agree with what's been said so far
so um
yes i thank you council richard so
everyone's happy
i think let's uh let's go to the vote on
this uh
let me try and straighten this out so we
all understand
it's been proposed and seconded that we
approve this application
with the in it with the additional uh
conditions
uh that are set out in the update sheet
as well
uh i think everyone's happy with that um
and
i see you're ready to go to the roll
call i'll begin councillor kendall
four thank you councillor
councillor adam councillor adam
four councillor dixon
councillor dixon
thank you councillor jennings councillor
jones for
councillor parry parry four
and councillor richards councillor
richards four
unanimous chairman wonderful thank you
very much
uh therefore the committee resolves to
grant application reference
zero zero six one three slash rem with
the additional conditions
uh that are in the update sheet and we
can move to our next application which
is item six we'll take a
five minute german and meet back soon
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
right i believe we've got all the
speakers ready for this application
yes lovely thank you right let's restart
meeting please
okay so we're back um i think we're
ready to move on
uh just i think you know at the end of
this application we move to our final
application there'll be no need for a as
as said there's no need for that so we
don't need to have other germans
okay let's move to item six this is
found on page
35 of your agendas tonight uh this is
application
reference twenty slash zero zero one
eight
zero slash bearing uh and it's for dutch
barn main street long compton
uh the application is seeking to amend
condition numbers
two and four and i think given it's
quite a lengthy description i'll move
to presenting officer joseph brooke i'll
let you take over from there
thanks very much
can everybody see that
perfect lovely brilliant
the application before you is uh on the
western side of long continent as
indicated by the black dot
for you
the bar as demonstrated by the plan
before you is situated approximately 270
meters from the physical confines of
long compton
so obviously the barn and there's the
physical confines you can see
of long compton and it's situated also
within the aomb
and an open countryside location
commission was granted in 2017
so they changed the use to of the bands
to provide two holiday cards
this application is seeking permission
to remove the requirement to keep the
shutter doors as part of the original
application
so this is the proposed elevations the
shutter doors
would be removed from this fenestration
detail here
and this fenestration detail here
at the minute this is the approved plans
with the shutter doors so as you can see
the two shutter doors
there and the large one
there this is photograph that works
that's currently in the place
of the last ship the door would be
placed there
as well as two shutter doors that we
placed on that elevation there
this is the previous works and you can
see the the
doors that would be put back on if
permission was refused
and the two there
as you will see there's two updates on
the update sheet uh
that's for the condition for landscaping
and hard and soft landscaping
isn't required because it's not a
requirement as part of the previous very
application
and also additional condition for the
application
for materials to be in accordance with
the already approved discharge
conditions
thank you chair
thanks very much joseph much appreciated
and right
let's go to our first speaker uh we've
got down here uh
councillor giant blackwell along compton
parish council
uh councillor blackwell are you there
can you hear us
star six twelve mute template
hello hello there hi we can hear you now
i think if you muted the device that
you're watching the proceedings on
um right yeah i thought i just had
actually rotated
it yeah okay
stop that's perfect expertly done right
so
you have uh three minutes to speak on
this
uh we'll give you a warning in the last
30 seconds and at the end of
your time please don't hang up we may
have some questions for you
over to you thank you good evening
everybody
this part has been through several
incarnations starting life as an
agricultural barn for the storage of hay
for which it was never used
then a change of use to enable it to be
used for business
again it was never used for that purpose
culminating in the previous owners
applying for a change of use to holiday
lets
and this is the basis from which this
present variation starts
the barn was sold and the current owners
first put in a variation to revise the
layout
and change the colour which the parish
council supported
one of the main concerns was light
spillage from the roof lights and the
many windows and doors
the barn is in close proximity to
recreation ground which is a registered
dark sky site
endorsed in the neighbourhood plan as is
the nearby roll right stones
it is also in the alb and in open
countryside
making any lights village highly visible
to the surrounding area
to this end the applicants agreed to
roller shutter doors and blackout blinds
the second variation was again a
revision of drawings
and the replacement of the roller
shutter doors with sliding doors
the parish council made no
representation
this brings us to the current variation
which seeks to remove the sliding doors
and install either motorized blackout
lines or curtains to all windows and
doors
the parish cancers objections arise from
wishing to know how the applicant could
be certain
that any occupants will make sure these
are utilized at the appropriate time
to stop any light spillage interfering
with these dark sky sites
and thereby complying with the long
compton neighborhood plan and the aonb
thank you
lovely thank you very much uh councillor
do we have any uh
questions from the committee to the
parish council please
please indicate in the chat
there's nothing coming up so i say to
you councillor blackwell thank you very
much for your time much appreciated
um thank you and we can move on to our
next speaker
okay we move to uh
mr david johnston the applicant and uh
mr simon cattle who's the agent i
believe he's only here to answer
questions
do we have you gentlemen on the line
star six to unmute
hi there hello hi
so i mean finding cables here okay so
we've got simon
and we've got david excellent uh so
david
mr sorry mr johnson i believe you're
going to be uh speaking on this am i
correct
yes yes i will just quickly um hi
everyone and and good evening and thank
you for your time
i'm david johnston the proud owner of
the property with my wife
uh laura and our three children i run a
design studio up here in london
and um we've fallen in love with the
property and particularly the area
uh which reminds me fondly of where i
was brought up near ross and my and
hericachia
all i really want to relay this evening
is my fondness of the area and the
community as well as my desire to make
it the best it possibly can be
as a property along with crucially an
intent that the barn is to be used
in its future respectfully by people
that are there
to enjoy its peaceful design and its
connection to the surrounding area of
natural beauty
the project has been designed by
architects turner works who put purpose
communities in respect for the
environment
at the heart of all they do and i think
that's probably a good point to hand
over to simon from
turner works brilliant thank you david
uh yeah i just um thought it would be a
good opportunity for me just to
cover off a couple of the key points um
that we're looking at today essentially
uh our application seeks to amend a
prior condition for externally mounted
shutter doors
to the outside of the barn our key
points for
looking to amend this condition firstly
we believe that the provision of
internal motorized blackout bindings and
curtains
to all windows doors and skylights will
be
will provide sufficient privacy and
light control
um on the details we submitted you you
will have seen that um
you know we are looking for the for
those blinds and curtains to be fitted
uh wider and higher than the glazed
openings to prevent any chance of
light spillage um the internal motorized
blackout vines and curtains would be
closed in any case where internal lights
are turned on and after sunset
and with these being motorized it is
very easy for them to be automated and
controlled remotely or
or by a climber and
this will further prevent the risk of
jeopardizing uh the dark skies site um
where the
where the barn is situated uh the
introduction
of the external shutters um whether
sliding folding
or rolling uh to a large window or dull
opening will add uh additional
complexity to the ease of emergency
escape for inhabitants and that's one of
the key reasons why we
would like to have them have them
removed from the condition for the for
the safety of the users of the building
um and therefore the only really uh
occasion where external shutters would
be able to be closed
is when the property is not in use
at which point uh there wouldn't be any
internal lights turned on
or a need for additional privacy uh to
you to use as
it wouldn't be in use um the previous
application
would have relied on occupants going
outside each night and manually closing
the external shutters and doors to
ensure
light control is achieved however the
alternative use of motorized blackout
blinds and curtains will remove the risk
of this
and allows for it to be automated and
also
avoid the need for users to venture
outside in
poor weather um to go and uh you know
close some rather large doors and
and yeah we would just like to reiterate
uh okay perfect thank you
well that is the end of your three
minutes so much appreciate it um
members of the committee if you have any
questions please um indicate in the chat
before we do that i have just one
question you touched on it briefly
uh during what you were saying i'm not
sure if this is a question
perhaps for the agent um you said that
the internal
blinds that are going to be motorized
they can be put on a timer so that
even if the building is not occupied
they can be set to roll down at
sunset i presume is that what you meant
yeah that's exactly correct
lovely okay that's fine no other
questions are appearing in the chat
so i'll assume that nobody else wants to
ask any questions gentlemen thank you
very much for your time tonight much
appreciated
thank you thank you thank you
okay we moved to our final speaker on
this application and this is the
uh our ward member councillor whaley
hoggins
who is already online you have five
minutes good evening and welcome
uh five minutes although you don't feel
you have to use all of them uh unless
you really want to of course
uh we'll give you a warning at 30
seconds and over to you
good evening everybody i'm quite sure a
warning won't be necessary
i'm here this evening as both the
district councillor for long compton
and in my capacity as a board member for
the cotswold
area of outstanding natural beauty when
the original permission for the dutch
barn was given for conversion to a
residential property
it was not received with universal joy
and delight
as there were concerns about the impact
this building would have
on the village and also the use of the
building
it is in a somewhat isolated position in
the village as has already been shown
to you and um as one would expect for
building that was used
originally for agricultural purposes
in order to obviate the concerns
planning conditions were attached to the
regional commission
which included ensuring that there would
be no light pollution from the building
and the planning conditions attached the
permission reflected this
these conditions were agreed by the
developers and their agents
and included a specific type of shutter
which would not only
reflect and pay homage to the original
purpose of the building
as well designed to be used for
agricultural purposes
but would also ensure that the unique
and important landscape of long compton
would be preserved
i am appalled therefore that we find
ourselves sitting here to discuss the
removal of these conditions
no objections relating to the ability to
address the building in an emergency was
made by building control of the
developers
at the time so this should not be a
consideration
as it is merely an excuse to overturn uh
the original
um conditions attached to the permission
there is no guarantee that using
motorized blinds or curtains will ensure
that there is light control
such blinds and curtains could fail to
be used by temporary occupants
and could be changed at any time by
future owners
the long compton neighborhood plan has
been fully accepted by stratfor district
council
the long compton neighborhood
development plan states quite clearly
that it is extremely anxious to preserve
the dark skies over the village
and to that end created a policy within
the ndp
that was their policy named as dark
skies the policy states
that development proposals will only be
supported if they do not jeopardize the
status of long compton's dark skies
this is supported by several paragraphs
of explanation
that includes the following there are no
street lights in the village
a situation the vast majority of
residents have repeatedly said
they do not wish to change as they
greatly value the blanket of stars which
cover the area
the site is regularly used by renowned
astronomers
and for educational visits long compton
is one of very few places in the british
isles
where the milky way is visible to the
naked eye
and the dark skies of long compton
protect rare bat species
therefore it is of paramount importance
that should that there should be as
little light spillage as possible
and it was preserved from this building
and it was precisely because of this
that the condition you are being asked
to overturn this evening
was put in place when the original
planning permission
was granted all the policies in this
district council's core strategy
regarding the importance of protecting
the particular character
and quality of particular neighborhoods
are also relevant
including a very important policy cs11
which states those parts of the area of
outstanding natural beauty
that lie within the district are defined
as tranquil areas
where the minimization of noise traffic
congestion
and light pollution is a priority
small scale developments and activities
are appropriate
in accordance with policy as-10
countryside abilities
but must not harm the historic or built
character
local distinctiveness or landscape
quality of the aonb
indeed the government has the highest
status of protection
relating to areas of outstanding natural
beauty in relation to the landscape
and the scenic beauty
the village of long compton lies within
the area of outstanding natural beauty
this building is absolutely within
that area of outstanding natural beauty
and the proposal would greatly diminish
that natural beauty and particularly
that which makes this village
particularly beautiful
rare and exceptionally special at night
i asked this committee to value the long
compton neighborhood plan
and to protect the cotswold area of
outstanding natural beauty
by rejecting this vexatious and
potentially destructive
application thank you
thank you very much councillor uh we've
already had a question
uh so uh councillor dixon you have a
question for the ward member
thank you chairman uh good evening sarah
um
obviously it may be a misunderstanding
on my part but
my understanding is that in they want to
replace shutters
which would be closed externally with
blinds
um how can the um
residents of long compton ensure that if
the
the shutters remain that the shutters
are closed at night
thank you
well the the point being that the
application
was only granted and went forward
because of these
because the shutters were agreed to and
of course
that is because it makes the dutch ban
continue to look like
a dutch barn really right for
agricultural purposes
rather than the dwelling house and
that's really my argument here
so it's essentially aesthetics
it's not aesthetics because actually the
shutters absolutely guarantee
no light pollution and we don't know the
type of materials that these blinds
will be made of they will be replaced in
the future by future residents
and it and occupants so we have no
control over that but if we do have
control
over using shutters on this development
if shutters have to be used
then they have to be used whereas
there's there's too many
um with the use of blinds and curtains
there are too many
ifs and buts with that
okay thank you very much uh there are no
further questions in the chat
box so i'll assume further questions
from the committee councillor hoggins
thank you very much for your time
tonight as well
much appreciated you're welcome thank
you
okay uh committee uh let's go to points
of clarification
uh do we have any questions
i'm going to start one off if that's
okay i have a question to start with
um right we've heard a lot of concerns
about whether or not these
how do we guarantee that these shuttles
will close on time
um either alice uh whoever
or joe i'm this would am i writing
assuming this would be a matter of
enforcement if they they don't close
it would be an enforcement issue uh the
honest truth is
chair um we can't enforce people to
close them shutters and we can't force
people to close
the internal blinds we have to highlight
this is internal so it's the same as a
host
not closing their windows uh their
blinds in the house or going outside
and closing them the shirt doors so
if there's no way to enforce that they
will be used
either instances the reason that we feel
this is more appropriate is
we can request for specifications that
our times and are rolled out
and in more likelihood people will be
inside
willing to close the curtains and use
time
shutters rather than going outside and
manually closing the big shutter doors
be honest that's the honest truth that's
fair point thank you very much for that
joe i appreciate it
um okay uh other questions let's me let
me run down these uh so um
councillor jennings uh you have a point
of clarification
you just asked the question i was going
to ask whether there's any way
like i was or struggling to see any way
that you could
unless you put someone up there saying
close those windows or close those
shutters or make sure
they did it every day it as a bit of a
head scratcher so i
just thank you you've asked the question
it's been clarified thank you councillor
um next question from councillor parry
thank you chair um i was just
interesting interested to know what the
specific time
scales the conditions actually
stipulated
is it is it sunset to sunrise or
um can you just confirm that
sorry i just want to make sure clear do
you mean the conditions
if it was approved for the details to be
submitted and proved
or do you mean the original the the
original plan
the original condition doesn't have a
requirement on time the original
planning condition is just so there's no
no so there's no requirement on specific
time scales
um
so it's literally i just remain in
perpetuity it's as simple as that
so i think if this this sorry to button
counselor harry it feels like the the
the acknowledgement of the dark skies
initiative was more of an ambition in
the first place than anything else
am i wrong in saying that i can't
comment on that i wasn't your isn't off
so i'm sorry to say
i can't comment i think i think
everybody understands where we're going
with this one
um okay counselor parry if you're
satisfied too
yeah i'm just i'm just i'm just a little
bit surprised
because normally any conditions that are
set
have to be reasonable and i'm just
surprised
there isn't if if it was a condition
that was put in place
it would be normally conditions are put
in place
that are enforceable and if we've got no
time scales on a condition
that can't be enforceable why was the
condition put there in the first place
technically you're absolutely on what
you're saying character technically
it is enforceable because the condition
is worded for the shutter doors to
remain
in perpetuity so if the shutter doors
are removed
then we can go back in enforcement
action
but it wouldn't be enforceable same as i
said it's internal lights
we can't expect people to go up there
and as council jennings
can't you point out and just say no you
must close them shutter doors
it's not enforceable there's no way to
enforce that
okay thank you i think that's been very
helpful
um next question counselor
no no it was me sorry um just a
a question around whether or not you
could
add something like the word automated
into condition three
to make sure that the shutters do close
in an automatic time
or whether that's anything that's
possible
in some ways i guess we could add it
i'll speak to alice but at the same time
we are asking for specification details
so
the specifications in themselves if we
didn't think they were
like if he if the applicant just
submitted usual curtains
we would just say i'm sorry that's not
acceptable so the condition is kind of
like we want the details and then we can
certainly
look into what the motorizations is on
them
and so forth um so it's kind of already
covered but
i mean i guess we could automate it but
i might give you that over to alice if
she thinks
are you content yeah yeah well
it's really down to members i mean i
think it's reasonable to add the word
uh so it would be price occupation
details of any
um automated integrated blackout blind
so i think it would be reasonable to add
that word in if members
want the the sort of comfort that when
we do get the details to discharge
we can ensure that they are automated
we've obviously got the go ahead from
the applicant because they they've
referred to that in their speech tonight
so
if members did want to do that i i'd be
happy for you to
to do that thank you alice okay uh
final question uh councillor jennings
yeah i'm sorry now i'm just so
absolutely clarifying here because
obviously there's a bit of confusion
there i think that
that there is there are no current
conditions that shutters need to be
closed
no the the the shutters must remain in
perpetuity is the condition
um there's no requirement and there
couldn't be no requirement it wouldn't
be forceful
to say them shutters have to be closed
at nine o'clock or ten o'clock
or whatever there's there's no
requirement
brilliant thank you very much right i
think those
points clarification have actually been
very very useful i think it helped a lot
uh to cast a little light on what we're
doing here
so dickson's got a further question
just coming count sticks and apologies
counselor dixon over to you thank you
sorry sorry chairman it was essentially
if we're going to be looking at that
condition three can we stipulate or do
the members wish to stipulate
that the blinds should be down from
sunset to sun
rise
i'll be honest it won't be enforceable
it is the same as having your
your house with curtains we can't force
someone to close
the curtains it wouldn't meet the six
tests i'm sorry to say
um it's just not enforceable uh the risk
i think we are relying on the goodwill
of the homeowners to do that really
um and i don't think there's anything
else we can enforce on that matter
um right okay with that being said let's
go to the debate
would anybody desperately like to start
off on this
i'm happy to begin uh just for a change
i cannot given the very good airing of
every issue we've had on this
i cannot see any any reason
not to go along with the approval of
this application
um i would back the inclusion of the
word automated
uh in the in condition three so it would
read um details of any
in uh automated integrated blackout
blinds
i would be happy to first go with that
as well that that's that's what i would
go with
um thank you i know it's a lot of people
rushing through here secondly i've not
actually managed to formally propose
this yet
but i will now do so so i will now
formally propose
uh with that edition and with the
updates and uh the
sorry i should say the additional
conditions in the update sheet which
we've noted
as well i will propose that we approve
this
application um who else would like to
speak so i've got uh councillor jennings
is next on the list over to you council
jennings
or would you just like to second
i'd just like to second thank you
in that case council adam do you wish to
speak
uh thanks chair only in as much as
obviously the automated idea was me
was my sorry put my teeth back in
um and the balance of health and safety
versus
large shutters that people have to move
on the outside of buildings versus
ones that can be controlled internally
to me sounds
a better idea so here we go
thank you council adam um councillor
parry
thank you chairman um i've just got a
few observations really
i think first of all one of the most
important things is long
long compton was the first parish
council to adopt
the neighborhood a neighborhood
development plan
which i think is really um quite an
important point apart from anything else
um
a lot of a lot of other parishes have
followed
in the lead of long compton in terms of
its development and design
um from my point of view
my my biggest issue is i can't find a
planning reason
to to to refuse this but what i would
like to say
is that i think the shutters actually
retain the sort of design and
agricultural sort of character
element of the dutch barn um
and you know from a cosmetic point of
view if it's more convenient for the
owners
they can easily put curtains automated
curtains on the inside so that at least
the barn retains its
look and design and i think it'll
i think i think removing the shutters
will detract from the overall
character of the dutch barn um
but i'm struggling at this moment in
time i'm still trying to see if i can
find a
a good reason to to refuse it because i
feel
the practicalities of automated blinds
and curtains
the owner can do that anyway i'm more
concerned
you know um there's a principle at stake
the
the shutters can't be enforced to close
neither can the curtains or the blinds
and i think you know the the points made
by the parish council
um and the ward member are certainly
very valid
um so i'm i'm just going to try and see
if i can find
anything in my my my reasons to refuse
predominantly on the character but it's
a variation and which makes it very very
difficult
but i'm it's one of those things it's
it's not
it's not an application that i feel
particularly comfortable with because i
think
as i say the ward member and the parish
council made some very valid reasons
we can't enforce we can't enforce
curtains we can't enforce blinds
we can't enforce shutters but i think it
does detract
from the overall look and positioning of
of the barn which is of more concern to
me so
i'm just giving it a little bit more
thought chairman
thank you councillor perry uh perhaps uh
if we move to
councillor richards he seems to have
something to add on this one council
richards
uh thank you chad i wasn't planning to
add too much but um i i
i sympathize with what uh councillor
perry has said there i wonder if there's
some way we can put a note on any
decision that we do make
to the effect uh of of what council
barriers just said
well i i would support a note uh that
would
that would indicate that sort of an
aspiration for what would be going
forward i think that's the best we can
do
alice would you agree um by all means we
as you know we can add notes they're not
enforceable but they obviously do serve
to advise the applicant the only thing
i'd just like to clarify is what exactly
we would want the note
to say because obviously i i understand
from
what counselor harry has said is that
the desire is for the shutters to stay
but obviously that isn't what the
applicant is applying for so i'm just
interested to know
how we could not obviously the specific
wording but the general gist of a note
that you would you would like adding
um my initial thoughts i think i would
suggest
uh somewhere along the lines of uh
precise wording obviously to go
you can work on but uh we would expect
or hope
that the applicant
uh abides by the neighborhood plan
which is to respect the aspirations
towards dark skies
uh and the shutters not sorry shut us
the
blinds the automated blinds be on a
pre-programmed
setting uh that would match sunset
sunrise times um i think that's
broadly where i would go with that i'm
not sure if councillor parry does
she agree just a nod would do or if you
want to come in
i mean i was i mean at the end of the
day i do feel that the room
not having the shutters to a certain
degree
um you know will will have an adverse
effect
um on the character of the actual
building because it won't reflect
it it it it would just
it would enhance the design i mean that
was probably why they were proposed in
the first place to give it that sort of
agricultural feel
so you know it is in a um
i believe long compton is in a
conservation area
and i'm just concerned that the removal
of the shutters would have an adverse
effect of the
of the development on the character and
appearance
um particularly in view you know it's
it's in the anob and and you know
even from a cosmetic point of view i
just think
aesthetically the building would look
better
with some form of um
you know and that's that's what concerns
me you know
i think we've got but it's not a strong
enough um
reason to refuse on on a variation
of a condition that's that that's my big
issue
i mean if if i had a strong planning
reason i would be
refusing but i do think we need to
protect the design
i think we need to respect the long
compton neighborhood development plan
which has been a beacon as far as
all the other neighborhood development
plans in
stratfor district which many others have
followed
and i think i think the wishes of the
parish council
and the ward member need to be respected
in that respect
thank you councillor perry um i minded i
i'm still look i'll be honest with the
committee i feel we're starting to go in
circles on this
uh i i i'm not with the best will in the
world council of harry i don't think
we're gonna be able to get to
a solution that you're gonna be 100
happy with so i apologize for that
um i think i'm reminded that we've got
council dixon who would like to comment
would you like to come in or do you feel
we actually go out anything at this
point very briefly chairman
i'm assuming and looking at those
photographs the role of the blinds are
vertical
and if they were up they would be out of
sight and there would be no aesthetic
value
except when they are down which is when
they're going to be closed
i can't see keeping the shutters of any
value
thank you councillor dixon councillor
jennings do you wish to come back here
you have indicated
yeah that's exactly what i was going to
say
i i i think we're going around in
circles i i don't really think we're
going to come to a resolution that's
going to please
everyone here i i just i don't see the
shutters as being
reasonable i don't think it's a strong
enough reason for us to
uh to go against the officer's
recommendation that's my personal view
it seems to be reflected by the majority
of the committee
um unless anybody desperately wants to
come in
yes alice uh go for it please
sorry i was just gonna clarify before we
go to the vote in terms of um the
proposal which is on the table can you
just clarify whether you do want that
note
um adding so i've taken note of what you
said and obviously precise wording to be
delegated if you're okay with that
um but if you could just clarify that
that would be appreciated i would like
yes i would like that note added it's
their aspirations it covers what i think
a number of the points were that came up
from both parish council
and the ward member in terms of
aspirations regarding darts guys i think
that would help
i understand it's not enforceable um my
second
of course was councillor jennings uh i
guess you're happy with that as well
lovely um and so it looks like everybody
else is
right let's move this on then shall we
um we have a proposal to approve uh with
the additional conditions that are in
the
update sheet and with the additional
note and
the changes to the wording of
amendment number three to include the
word automated
it's been proposed it's been seconded
kick us off and with the roll call
councillor kendall
four thank you councillor adam
councillor adam four thank you
councillor dixon
councillor dixon four
councillor eden councillor eddon four
councillor jennings councillor jennings
fall
councillor parry councillor parry
against
and councillor richards councillor
richards four
six four and one against chairman thank
you very much anne
okay so the committee resolves therefore
to grant application
reference twenty slash zero zero one
eight
zero slash very um with of course the
additional comments and the moments
okay we go to our final application
tonight because there's no need for us
to take a break at this point
um hopefully we can rattle through this
one quite quickly
a little bit of luck um this is then
found on page 45 this is
application reference 20 0
five nine five slash ful and is for 29
swanford film codes and is for the
garage conversion with a raised roof
line
and internal alterations presenting
officer victoria chadway
victoria over to you i can see it
already it's fine
perfect great you anticipated the
question uh
so the application site is in warm coat
which is within the designation of the
green belt and indicated by the black
dot
uh this shows the red line outline of
the site it's a detached bungalow on a
corner plot
this is the bungalow in question the
uh garage which is proposed for
conversion is in front of the car
and the proposal quite simply is to
increase the height of the garage by
about well by half a meter
to enable the internal conversion of the
garage to habitable
accommodation in conjunction with the
house of a master bedroom and an ensuite
in um greenbelt terms it amounts to
a 4 increase of the overall dwelling
and the reason this has come to
committee is because the applicant
is an employee of the council the
recommendation is to
grant consent subject to the conditions
detailed in the committee report thank
you
perfect thank you very much uh excellent
report
um okay we have no registered speakers
on this one we all know the reasons come
to committee
um we do have councillor shenton on the
line if any many members of the
committee
feel they need to question him on this
i'll give it
five seconds in the chat should you wish
to
thank you well in that case let's do
this by the book please
uh councillor richards uh you've
indicated you would propose grant do you
wish to speak on this
i don't think there's much i need to say
to be honest jess fantastic thank you
very much
um councillor eden you have indicated
you would like to second
the uh proposal to grant do you wish to
speak on this
nothing to add yet thank you very much
uh there's nobody else rushing to add
anything to the chat i notice
uh unless anybody has any points
clarification or anything they want in
the debate
let's go to the vote i'll kick us off uh
councillor kendall
uh four thank you
councillor adam
adam four thank you councillor dixon
councillor dixon for
jennings councillor jennings fall
councillor parry councillor parry four
councillor richards councillor richards
four
that's unanimous chairman thank you anne
so the committee therefore resolves to
grant application
reference uh twenty slash zero zero five
nine
five slash f u l that is our final
application for the evening we have no
urgent business unless anybody
on the committee wishes to uh raise
anything
i think we're okay in that case uh
excellent work everybody tonight thank
you to officers for excellent
presentations thank you for
all help that's gone into it and to all
of our speakers uh that are taking part
in tonight's meeting
therefore at uh 2020
appropriately meeting closed thank you
very much if we've gone
off live is counselor adam able to get
you